[Music]  Jennifer Lawrence and her boyfriend  Darren Aronofsky have split multiple  sources tell et the now-former couple  dated for about a year after working  together on a mother we spend all her  time here I want to make a paradise  Jennifer starred in the movie which  Darren directed working with your  partner Derek collaborated on this what  makes him so great  I mean he's his point of view is his  artistic the uniqueness he's just  brilliant he's incredibly instinctual  our sources say the break-up happens in  October and was amicable the pair remain  friends he's very unique I mean there's  not really anybody I can compare to he's  nobody like him  [Music]  you  [Music]